[Musique]
la maison du pain qui est un musée qui
retrace l'histoire du pain à travers les
âges et aussi en fournil qui présente
toutes les spécialités alsaciennes et
notamment aujourd'hui au salon de
l'agriculture avec jean-claude in this
boulanger meilleur ouvrier de france
nous avons proposé des brèdes celle aux
céréales nous debrecen qui s'était
réalise
et avec de la farine de seigle de la
farine complète et la farine de blé et
puis débridé laisse aller avec du
parmesan soupoudré 2
graine de différentes sortes de graines
alors on a utilisé des graines
tournesol des graines de lin est un
mélange de
de graines de boulanger alors on a
permis aux visiteurs du salon de
découvrir une autre variété de deux
bretelles aux céréales qui a été très
fort appréciée on a écoulé tous les sea
dogs
[Musique]
il
pour
[Musique]